have you wondered what it would be like
to be an astronaut floating around in
the space station why are the astronauts
floating I'm here at the Powerhouse
Museum in Sydney to find out if anyone
knows the answer
why are they floating in their gravity
in our graphic zero-gravity
there's my gravity's
the stuff that holds us to the planet
brumis beam doesn't happen up there
gravity holds you the answer in space
there's nothing there they just float
there's no gravity in space no greater
that's very little but is there really
no gravity in space after all the moon
orbits the earth due to gravitational
attraction so where with the space
station fit in this picture can you make
me a roughly to scale model of the earth
and the moon and then we're gonna
position the space station in there so
try like that maybe then you ready to
see the real distance hmm how do you
reckon
Oh
it's actually about here maybe a little
further I think we were wrong
now if the moon is here and the earth is
there whereabouts would you put the
space station yeah
pity about halfway yeah right about here
so that's maybe like a quarter of the
distance to the moon let me show you the
real distance you ready for the real
distance the space station is right
about there
the space station is actually only about
four hundred kilometers away so if
you're in Sydney it's a little further
than the drive to Canberra but does it
make sense that the earth exerts a big
gravitational force on you but nothing
on the astronauts just a short distance
away
you reckon there be no gravity there
there's not much they flex we've seen
them well clearly there's not they're
floating around I know they float and
the question is why no idea
well in truth the force on the
astronauts is almost as much as the
force on you so then why are they
floating while you're stuck here the
answer is the astronauts aren't floating
they're falling and not only that but
the space station they're in is falling
as well ah
so why doesn't the space station come
crashing into the earth well the reason
is the space station and astronauts
inside have this huge sideways velocity
of about 28,000 kilometers per hour so
even though they're falling towards the
earth they're going so fast that as they
fall towards the Earth's surface it
curves away from them if the earth
didn't put a gravitational force on them
they would fly out into space
sure yeah right so it's due to that
gravitational pull that they can
actually keep orbiting the earth if it
was to stop moving and it would be
plummeting exactly what would they they
would still feel weightless until you
smash into something so the space
station and the astronauts inside are
constantly accelerating towards the
Earth's core but they never get any
closer and because they're accelerating
at the same rate the astronauts feel
weightless they have this amazing
sensation of floating
you